President Trump is defending his first
concrete proposal or compromise since
the shutdown began congressional
Republicans plan to push the plan the
president unveiled over the weekend in
it he offered immigration concessions in
exchange for billions in border wall
funding major Garrett is at the White
House with why a deal seems major like a
Carole King song so far away good
morning to you good morning indeed
you're right Gayle top advisers told
President Trump last week the negative
effects of the nation's longest
government shutdown will begin to worsen
rapidly starting this week stressed
bureaucracies will begin to buckle he
was told and federal workers and federal
contractors will really begin to feel
the economic pinch that prompted the
president to offer a compromise but he
didn't consult with top Democrats first
and they rejected it almost immediately
I want this to end it's got to end now
the president who once owned the
shutdown I will be the one to shut it
down now once to sell I am here today to
break the logjam as federal workers some
turning to food banks over this weekend
faced another round of miss paychecks
economic anxiety and pressure is
building both sides in Washington must
simply come together the president
offered protection from deportation for
some refugees and immigrants brought
here by their undocumented parents for
three years that in exchange for his
original 5.7 billion dollar wall funding
demand walls are not immoral the White
House wall language is also softening
from this campaign roar we're going to
build the wall folks precast concrete
going very high we have 1,000 miles that
we need to this downsize description
this is not a 2,000 mile concrete
structure from sea to sea these are
steel barriers in high priority
locations and while the White House is
using lofty language to sell the deal
one of my favorite quotes from dr. King
was now is the time to make real the
promises of democracy that's exactly
what President Trump is calling on the
Congress to do House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi called the plan a non-starter
Democrats who doubt the president's plan
could pass the House or Senate appear
unwilling
to budge offering some of those
protections that he took away back in
exchange for the wall is not a
compromise but hostage-taking Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell will
bring the president's plan to the Senate
floor this week along with other bills
to end the government shutdown that will
create a test vote to see if this
proposal can divide Democratic ranks and
if it does in John the White House will
have two choices bring top Democrats to
the table and compromise further or
declare a national emergency all right
major Garrett thanks very much